I was I was just reading an email from
somebody calling me a climate denier
because yesterday I said on the show
that I that I don't think the world is
coming to an end anytime soon
due to global warming you know I don't
think you need to go building an ark
because the polar ice caps are gonna
melt
and so that makes me a climate denier
yes I deny the climate that's right this
is what a my one of my favorite phrases
the left uses of all their euphemisms
and they're misleading and flatly
dishonest labels and and in terms that
they use this may be my favorite when
they call you a climate denier like yes
I I deny the climate it's true I I deny
that the climate exists I don't believe
in the climate I don't think there is
such a thing as a climate I think that
we live in a giant artificial dome much
like the Truman Show except this dome
according to my theory was built by
aliens
you know billions of years ago and
they're actually the aliens are on
platforms in the sky what looks like the
sky anyway it's actually just painted
blue but they're up there on the clouds
are actually these platforms and the
aliens are up there and they're dumping
they're dumping buckets of water to make
rain and they're rollin bowling balls
across wood floors to make thunder and
and that's that's my theory I deny the
existence of the climate now of course
for most people though when when you
call them a climate denier what you
really mean is they are apocalyptic
changes in climate cause specifically by
human activity deniers and that's what
most people are denying when they're
denying the climate and it may seem like
semantics to quibble over this but it's
really not because climate denier makes
you sound insane whereas anthropogenic
anthropogenic that's the word climate
change denier
sounds much more rational and that's a
little bit more difficult to say I admit
but there's a reason when someone says
climate didn't or even just climate
change denier nobody denies that is
everyone knows that climates change we
all agree that climates change all the
time
the issue
is why do they change what causes the
change and to what degree are these
different causes to blame and where is
it all leading and is the world coming
to an end soon I mean these are the
questions that were argument no one's
arguing about the existence of the
climate and no one is arguing even about
whether or not climate change okay and
in fact you know what nobody's even
arguing about whether or not humans have
some kind of effect I mean of course we
are part of the world we have an effect
farting cows have an effect volcanoes
have an effect the ocean has an effect
the Sun has a huge effect all of these
things have in effect the question is to
what extent to what degree do these
things affect the climate that's what
the issue is over alright quite a lot of
material to cover today but before we do
I want to tell you about hair club it's
important to have to have confidence of
course to feel to feel comfortable with
yourself and sometimes one change it
seems like a simple change may be that
some people seems even like a small
change if you're not going through it
but it makes a huge difference and
that's what hair club is all about hair
club is the leader in total hair
solutions so you know you're in good
hands and if you're looking to
revitalize your your hair growth you
know the hair that you already have or
if you want to learn more about hair
restoration or anything else related to
this hair clubs professionally trained
stylists experts and consultants they
can get with you and you can consult
with them and they will craft a
personalized solution to ensure that you
feel your best and you get the most out
of your hair it can be a difficult thing
you know for people to go through losing
their hair it's not something people
like to talk about but I know guys who
lost most or all their hairs you know
even even when they were pretty young
and it can be a real blow to your
confidence and answer your perception of
yourself but the point here is that
there are steps you can take so go to
hair club.com slash walsh today for a
free hair analysis and a free take-home
hair kit it's all valued at over three
hundred dollars but that's for free
Hair Club comm / Walsh for a free hair
Canales and free hair kit hair club comm
/ Walsh experience your hair and your
life at its best
ok let's turn to something utterly
outrageous and horrifying there's a bill
called this is difficult it's hard for
me to even talk about these I have to
try to control myself when I talk about
this sort of thing because it makes me
so angry and I have to watch what I say
a bill called the born alive abortion
survivors Protection Act failed in the
Senate last night maybe you heard about
this if you if you rely on the
mainstream media for your news you
probably did not hear about that we'll
talk about that aspect of it in a minute
but Senate Democrats blocked the bill it
was a bill sponsored by Ben Sasse every
single Democrat except for three Manchin
Casey and Jones those are the ones who
voted for the bill but all of the rest
of the Democrats every single one except
for those three voted against it now
what would this legislation have done
just like it says it would have required
doctors to give medical treatment to
infants that are born alive after a
failed abortion this is something that
happens especially with late term
abortions you could have babies that
survived it and are born alive and then
the question is which should not even be
a question but what do you do about the
child once he survives according to the
exact language of this bill it would
prohibit a healthy I'm reading now from
the bill prohibit health care
practitioner from failing to exercise
the proper degree of care in the case of
a child who survives an abortion or
attempted abortion it goes on if an
abortion results in the live birth of an
infant the infant is a legal person for
all purposes under the laws of the
United States and entitled to all the
protections of such laws any infant born
alive after an abortion or within a
hospital clinic or other facility has
the same claim to the protection of the
law that would arise for any newborn or
for any person who comes to a
Broll clinic or other facility for
screening and treatment or otherwise
becomes a patient within its care it
also prescribes criminal penalties for
anyone who intentionally performs or
attempts to perform an overt act that
kills a child born alive now there is
something called the born alive infant
Protection Act which was signed into law
and I think 2002 that by the way was
passed unanimously okay so every
Democrat in the Senate back in 2002
voted for the born alive infant
Protection Act and that what that law
did is it defines any child who's born
whether after an abortion or in any
other scenario as a human being but it
does not specifically prescribe what
must be done for these children it
doesn't specifically require doctors to
give medical care to the child it
doesn't it doesn't prescribe penalties
for doctors who fail to deliver that
treatment and so that's what this that's
what this law was supposed to do kind of
following on the heels of that one and
saying yeah that's a human being by the
way it's a human being and if it needs
medical treatment you need to give
medical treatment and you cannot kill
this human being you'd hope it wouldn't
be necessary right to pass a law like
this you'd hope that you wouldn't need a
law that actually specifically says hey
don't leave babies to die but in recent
weeks we've seen the Democrats have come
out in favor of infanticide and we've
seen them push the boundaries further
and further and further on abortion
legalizing later and later abortions so
that it did become necessary to add
these protections except Senate
Democrats voted it down every Senate
Democrat running for president just to
be clear every Senate Democrat running
for president voted against this bill
Cory Booker sherrod Brown Kirsten
Gillibrand Kamala Harris Elizabeth
Warren Bernie Sanders I'm I prefer
getting a couple all of them voted
against the beat the bill which means
just to really emphasize this what we're
talking about here is the Democrat Party
has officially unambiguously without
question come out in favor of
infanticidal they are saying then this
is not just some random crazy radical
and fantasise old democrat out there on
the fringes okay this is the mainstream
of the party the majority of the party
is now saying that babies who are born
out of the mother living and breathing
out in the world that those babies
should not be given legal protection and
that it should be legal to kill them
that's what they're saying
now remember Democrats spent the last
few weeks denying denying with great
moral indignation the the claim that
they support infanticide after after
Ralph Northam was was interviewed and he
very clearly advocated for infanticide
and but all the Democrats said no that's
not what we think that's not what he
said how dare you and when Republicans
accused them and said you guys support
infanticide Democrats said that's
ridiculous no we don't
and then what Democrat what Republicans
said last night was okay well so you
don't support and fanta said well then
just
I'm sure you'll support this bill then
that makes infanticide illegal and
Democrats said about that what does that
tell us it tells us that Democrats are
pathological liars as well as amoral
baby murder apologists and listen I know
that we're supposed to reach across the
aisle you know we're supposed to try and
be bipartisan we're supposed to see the
best in the other side and look for
common ground and blah blah blah blah
but I'm just telling you how I feel in
this moment and I'm being brutally
honest this is how it seems to me that
you cannot be a good person and remain
affiliated in any capacity with the
Democrat Party
if you see a vote like this and you
still call yourself a Democrat I don't
care if you're just an average Joe Blow
Democrat voter or politician whatever
after a vote like this if you still
remain affiliated with the Democrat
Party then you are a bad person you are
simply a bad person and I am ashamed to
share a country with you and I wish that
I didn't and if I'm calling 40 million
or 50 million Americans bad people then
so be it
now that said I recognize that many
average Americans who call themselves
Democrats may be extremely ignorant so I
guess maybe ignorant or evil are really
the only obvious if you're voting
Democrat if you're a Democrat those are
the only options I'm you're extremely
extraordinarily clinically ignorant or
you're a bad person
I there's not any there is no third
option there's no there's no option see
here right well the option see is both
maybe there's no option D and we know
that that the media is constantly
running cover for Democrats so that if
you rely on the mass media for your news
you might not even know about this vote
a lot of mass media outlets are just
ignoring it saying nothing about it
others are blatantly lying a quick look
at the news I just looked this up on
Google just to see what the headlines
are about this vote and I'll just read a
couple of a few headlines Senate defeats
anti-abortion bill as GOP tries to jam
Dems anti-abortion measure dies in US
Senate Democrats blocked Senate GOP
anti-abortion effort Senate vote on
abortion legislation fails to advance
measure us Democrats blocked born alive
anti-abortion bill okay so you get the
point the media is calling us an
anti-abortion measure which is just
simply a lie it actually has nothing to
do with abortion at all it deals with
infants that are born alive already
born infants and liberals are the ones
who are saying there's a distant no yes
I believe that there is no difference
between an infant born who's born an
infant who's not born yet it's the same
thing morally physiologically
philosophically all of that right but
they're the ones who say that there's
this huge distinction between the two so
by their own standards this was not an
anti-abortion bill this was a bill that
was a dealing with born infants with
with with with with human beings that
even they up until now would call baby's
not fetuses babies so these headlines
they're not just misleading these
headlines are blatant fabric
fabrications total lies these are
headlines that are literally based on
abortion industry talking points okay
the abortion industry is is is writing
their PR talking points and handing them
out to the media and the media is taking
those talking points and making them
into headlines that's what's happening
here near Al which is an abortion
lobbyist group and a collection of
despicable disgusting
scumbags tweeted this after the vote
they said breaking the senate has voted
down senators asses extremists
anti-science bill that attempted to
inflict medically unnecessary
restrictions on clinics spread dangerous
anti choice lies and threaten health
care providers with jail time extremists
yes it's extremists to refrain from
murdering already born infants right but
but this is the line that the Democrat
Party in the media has taken the
abortion Lobby gives them their talking
points and they repeat them dutifully
it's just these are just lies allies
that are meant to protect the slaughter
of children born children so the point
is if you're not informed if you're lazy
it's easy to be duped by this and to not
realize so there are probably average
voting Democrats who don't realize how
radically far left the party has gotten
but that's no excuse
you see EC we live in the information
age
you have no excuse to be ignorant you
have no excuse to not know about these
things I don't care who you are I don't
care where you live I don't care what
your situation is unless you're in a
coma you have no excuse to not know what
has become of the Democrat Party all I
mean just it doesn't take that much
research so the thing is you know yes I
I acknowledge that there are Democrat
voters who are who are extremely
ignorant and don't realize how evil the
party is but that ignorant now that is a
moral failing as well to be that
ignorant it's it's it's got to be that
you want to remain ignorant I mean what
we've reached a point where if you're if
you're a decent person you cannot
support this I don't know how else to
put it the Democrat Party is endorsing
in the killing of born children that's
where the line is drawn I'm not saying
you got to become a Republican I'm not
shilling for the Republican but I don't
care about that I mean be whatever you
want to be do whatever you want to do
take what but but youyou can't support
this the Democrat Party is this is what
they're about killing babies infanticide
and so that's where the line is drawn
it's just are you going to be a decent
person or not and if you're gonna be
decent you cannot possibly affiliate
yourself the Democrat Party isn't is an
evil institution with no morally
redeeming aspects about it at all
anymore speaking of being informed I
want to a play for you an exchange
between and this was all this also came
out yesterday as it happens this is an
exchange between fake Christian abortion
abortionist Willie Parker well he's he's
a real abortionist and a fake Christian
just to be clear and
and dr. Mike Adams so they had
interestingly enough they had a debate
at the University of North Carolina and
Willie Parker who's an abortionist
volunteered to publicly debate this it's
very rare you get a working abortionist
who's going to get up on stage and
debate somebody about abortion you
rarely see that these these Peas guys
they do not want to be in that situation
of having to defend what they do against
someone who's hostile to them and we're
gonna find out why here I think Willie
Parker is regretting putting himself in
this position and so I want you I'm
gonna play just one little clip from
this exchange I want you to watch this
so when you crush a human skull it's not
really gray Manor it's white brain
matter that uses out what's your point
no I'm asking you a question is is the
brain matter that oozes out when you
crush a human skull white whether the
matter you subscribe what I do so what
is your point my point is that an
intentionally kills an innocent human
being would you concede the point it
intent I started my my first concession
was to Europe first to cyllage and that
abortion kills a human being it is the
intentional disruption of a pregnancy it
kills human being how many innocent
human beings have you intentionally
killed in your life's work I don't know
I don't I don't
20,000 what's the difference what's the
difference between 20,000 and 30,000 now
10,000 dead human beings that's the
difference okay so you see the
abortionist admits that it is the
killing of a human being he says that
crushing skulls is an accurate
description of what he does remember
doctor dr. Adams says okay when you're
crushing ask all the brains ooze out and
Willie Parker says I won't call him dr.
Willie Parker says was you're just
you're describing what I do
so you know you don't have the point is
you don't have to search hard you don't
have to spend a lot of time to discover
that even the people in the abortion
industry admit if you catch them at the
right moment in the right mood they will
admit that this is what they do this is
killing that they kill people
it is violence it is death it is bloody
it is gruesome
that is what they do in the abortion
industry itself they're not having
debates about personhood right they know
that they're killing people persons they
know that they're not you know those are
debates for the rubes for the
pro-abortion rubes who are being
manipulated they're gonna have those
debates and make those kinds of
arguments the people in the abortion
industry they know they're not that
stupid they know better all right
but it look as I'm saying if you can
watch a video like that what I just
played for you and be on Willie Parker's
side I mean if you can watch that and
come away from it and saying yeah I'm on
that guy's side the guy who has lost
track of the number of human beings he
killed he's killed and doesn't even
think the body count matters if you're
gonna be on his side that I again how
can you how could I call you a decent
person I mean the word the phrase decent
person would lose all meaning if I could
apply it to someone who supports that
Alright a little bit more liberal
madness to talk about here
transgender sprinters that is male
sprinters guys dudes fellas they they
finished first and second at the girls
indoor track championships in in
Connecticut a few days ago and this is
we see these headlines of course all the
time now these particular least one of
these guys I think both of them but at
least one of them was in the headlines
last year for winning
tract check the girls track
championships last year might have an
outdoor the spring events last year so
this guy is Jay he's just dominating
he's just dominating the the female
circuit up in Connecticut racing all
these these girls who you know I laugh
at just the absurdity of it because what
else can you do but it's actually not
funny because these girls are being
they're having you know these girls are
working hard I ran track well you know I
ran against men when I was when I was in
high school and it's a it's hard I mean
running his heart and to be a
competitive runner is a hard thing it's
very challenging it takes a lot of work
a lot of effort a lot of exercise eating
right I mean you're running all the time
it's a really difficult sport and these
girls are working their butts off and
and putting everything they have into it
and but all for nothing because they
can't compete against the guy they did
they biologically physically can't if
you compare you look at any state right
and you you compare you look at the
girls Championships in whatever in any
track event whether it's a 200 meter or
the 800 meter is a mile whatever it is
and you could you look at the boys
versus the girls and assuming that
they're actually that they actually are
all boys and all girls and you compare
the top times for the boys to the girls
and it's just like you a time that would
get you first place in a girl's event
you wouldn't even make it onto the track
in the boys of it in the boys champion
you wouldn't even place you wouldn't
even get sixth place that's how much of
a gap there is and this is not an it's
not an insult about insulting girls or
anything no no it's just it's there
there are biological limitations men are
simply built in a certain way where
they're going to be faster and stronger
and so
these girls have no chance and all of
their hard work is being stolen and this
is this is cheating is what it is but
here's the interesting thing look I saw
I saw this story on Twitter saw whatever
news outlet reported it and this is this
is all anecdotal of course but I you
know I I looked at the comments under
the under the headline and in fact I
looked at a few I went and checked a few
headlines about this particular story
these transgenders winning against the
girls and I was looking at the comments
on Twitter and every single comment I
saw what was expressing some version of
this is crazy this is cheating totally
ridiculous I feel bad for those girls
every single coming hundreds of comments
I couldn't find one single person and I
know again that it's anecdotal but I
could not in my brief check I could not
find one single person who was defending
this and defending these guys and saying
yeah I think this is right yeah I think
we should have guys racing against girls
and taking their championships and
that's interesting isn't it because
we're told that this is a controversial
issue and for any other controversial
issue whether it's abortion or anything
else if I go on Twitter and I can easily
find people on all sides of it
expressing all the different views but
with something like this it's very
difficult to actually find a real human
being who will come out and say yeah I'm
in favor of this I think it's a good
idea when you do a quick survey of what
everyone's saying about a topic like
this it seems like everybody is against
it nobody thinks that this makes sense
and what does that tell you it tells you
that when it comes to this issue
especially the transgenderism and
especially when it comes to you know two
boys invading girls sports and girls
locker rooms and girls bathrooms what
you have is a tiny tiny tiny minority
which has imposed its will on the
majority this is the the tiniest
minority of
people and I'm not speaking just about
the the the Trent that transgenders
themselves who themselves are a tiny
minority but then you also have a tiny
minority the in the LGBTQ Lobby who are
pushing this the kind of extremist LGBT
activists they're the ones this is their
agenda this is what they want and they
are in a obviously in a very small
minority yet they're getting their way
and there's no reason for it there's no
reason to allow this if if the if the if
try if if the folks up there in
Connecticut were to pass a rule saying
you know what we're done with this if
you're if you're if you are a biological
male you cannot compete against girls if
they were to pass that rule in
Connecticut ninety nine percent it seems
of the country and of the people in
Connecticut would be totally in favor of
it and they would say that makes a lot
of sense there would only be that one
crazy percent that says no I are this
this is this is a bigoted this is unfair
to those boys who now aren't going to
have the opportunity to race against
girls you would have that one loud but
small percent there's no reason to
listen to them they don't really have
any but they only have the power we give
them that's the thing so it's kind of
even more pathetic in a way on one hand
I'm glad that we don't live in a country
yet where a majority of people are in
favor of something like this but on the
other hand it's really pitiful and sad
when you think about it that almost all
of us disagree with it yet we're it's
just going along with it anyway
all right I'm gonna jump ahead to to
some of your emails now Matt wall show
at gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
if you want to offer your opinions
questions whatever it may be and a bunch
of interesting emails so I want to get
to them before we run out of time this
is from Brandon says dear Matt why does
the Libertarian Party suck at everything
well you know Brandon I think that I
think the Libertarian Party has two
problems actually three the first is
that everyone's high all the time so I
think that's getting in the way
second is the perceived lack of cogent
see or focus I have noticed it's
interesting to think about the
Libertarian Party has not gained more
attention and attracted more people but
I think it's well most people can't
figure out exactly what the Libertarian
Party is or what libertarianism is or
what it stands for and I think
libertarians themselves don't know
exactly especially when it comes to
these really hot-button important social
issues like for instance abortion now
libertarians should be the first ones
getting up there and saying this is
wrong because libertarian is supposed to
be you know the do no harm right the
anti aggression principle is supposed to
stand for individual liberty and when
you have something that is an assault on
human life then that obviously is also
an assault on Liberty so Lib and there
are some pro-life libertarians but there
are also radically pro-choice
libertarians and if you don't have a
coherent viewpoint on an issue as
fundamental and important as that then
it's going to be really hard for people
to for you to attract people because
people everyone else we don't know what
you're all about and the third thing is
I think libertarian party needs more
compelling figures to carry its banner I
mean Gary Johnson who is the libertarian
party not Gary Johnson
it's the libertarian party you need to
find someone who's young exciting
interesting kind of weird I that's what
the libertarian party should be not Gary
Johnson
this is from Gareth says hi I'm a big
fan of your show I love your dry humor
and down-to-earth and common sense
approach to religion and politics I've
noticed that it seems like daily wire is
giving you more lately with a table to
sit at and a fancy new microphone and
actually the microphone is gone as you
noticed and yesterday you even got to
have a sponsor
is there any chance Ben will let you in
the studio to do a backstage with the
other guys yeah I go to this I've been
going to the studio every every day for
the last year and a half
and it's been locked but in fact
recently they let me in the lobby but
they lock the doors to get actually back
into the studio so I'm making up no
actually the UCI what's actually the
interference here is 3,000 miles where I
live and on the East Coast and the daily
wires headquartered out there in Los
Angeles so that's where the you know
that's where the separation comes comes
from although I will mention that I will
soon be a part of one of the backstage
show so I'm looking forward to that but
I have to fly all the way out there for
that you know so that's the only thing
this is from Mike says yesterday you
said that you thought you approve of
alcohol tobacco use for relaxing when
done responsibly and in moderation the
same rationale could be used to
justified marijuana use I'm curious what
your position is on this since some
people prefer to smoke we need to relax
instead of drinking whiskey that's an
interesting question Mike I don't know
the the answer I don't know enough about
it to answer I've always thought that
there's a definite difference between
alcohol and marijuana or tobacco and
marijuana certainly in that alcohol for
one thing is a much more at least my
impression a much more social substance
and it seems that you can have one drink
and be barely affected by it at all just
feeling a little bit relaxed but other
than that you're completely lucid and
fine
whereas marijuana it seems will have a
much more profound effect much quicker
but whenever I've made that argument
I've been informed by people who smoke
marijuana that I'm totally wrong and I
don't know what I'm talking about and
maybe that's true I don't smoke the
stuff personally so I suppose I'm just
giving my general impression which could
be wrong I will say this is what I'll
say
okay I think a substance can be
perfectly fine perfectly moral and even
actively wholesome in a certain context
if it is possible to consume it without
being intoxicated by it losing control
of your reason and your senses and if it
is not physically dangerous at least
within moderation if it's not
immediately addictive and if it has some
positive effect such as as I mentioned
facilitating healthy social interaction
relaxation and so on so whatever that
applies to I would say in moderation it
would seem to me to be perfectly moral
does that apply to marijuana I I have
thought no but I could be wrong so I'm
not sure this is from Derrick hi Matt
I'm a huge fan of your show I love the
religious and political commentary but
must admit my favorite part are your
rants about the idiosyncrasies of
marriage and the ever elusive male
understanding of the female psyche my
wife is a soap addict as well the
struggle is real yes it is I just wanted
to offer an opinion about the Bill Maher
clip from yesterday I agree with
everything you said but what stuck out
to me most was how thoroughly convinced
he is that all of the feelings he
mentioned are universally desirable what
sheer and utter arrogance to assume you
know what other people desire I was born
and raised as a liberal in California I
have a career that keeps my family and
I'm moving around the country quite a
bit I have lived in many major cities
most in very blue areas when I retire my
wife and I plan to move to the country
buy a piece of land own 12 dogs and
enjoy the tranquility of worl America
until we die my point being I have
experience living in all sorts of
geographic economic regions and can say
with objective certainty that I desire
the rural life in this clip Maher says
there's no CSI Lubbock it turns out that
exorbitant amounts of murder don't plate
take place in rural America interesting
fact Lubbock is where Buddy Holly was
born he can keep the rat the red carpet
that all of those self-aggrandizing
narcissist he is so fond of like to walk
down it seems he just can't conceive of
people valuing church family and
community more than a Tesla they were
instead of Louis Vuitton not because
they're downtrodden but because they
know the true value of material items
and couldn't give a rip about whose name
is embroidered on the rear end they'd
probably be far happier spending the
money they'd saved buying target clothes
on Budweiser or whatever other beer bill
finds beneath his standards I dislike
the two Americas perspective as well
there are good and not-so-good people
from every walk of life I just like vast
generalizations but for Bill I will make
an exception the difference between
elitist celebrities like Bill Maher and
red Staters is that elitist celebrities
like Bill looked down on the rest of the
country making fun of it with
unwarranted hubris and misguided disdain
the red Staters while often in a similar
state of disbelief of the chosen
lifestyles of their fellow Americans
offer people like him prayers in return
thanks for what you do keep up the good
work very eloquently put Derrick I wish
that maybe you should just be doing the
show because I think you had a lot more
interesting things to say about that
clip than I did and that is one thing
that struck me as well when you know
you're watching that clip and especially
the red carpet line where Bill Maher
says we have red carpets okay you think
the rest of us want red carpets you
think that's what we care about we have
celebrities it is Bill really doesn't
understand them most people don't care
about that I I don't I don't care to
live in a place but oh there's a
celebrity what is a celebrity a
celebrity is just a person who a lot of
people are aware of that's all a
celebrity is it's not so I don't need
this is--that's I don't need to live in
a place where there are a lot of people
who a lot of other people are aware of
you know it's just like why who cares
doesn't make it bad people doesn't make
them good people it's just it's a
totally neutral thing it could be that
whatever you do for a living if it
happens to me in the public eye a lot of
people will be aware of you who cares
and I think Derrick the point you bring
up is a good one that bill is so
disconnected from the experience of many
average people that he really doesn't
understand that we don't care about that
if we did we could easily look if any
one of us wanted to move to California
we could we live where we live as a
choice right well some of us I mean I I
do live on the East Coast and so I live
in a more liberal area and I mean there
are aspects of where you live that is
but the point is if it was really here's
what I mean if it was really a priority
like if we you know if we listen to that
rant from Bill Maher and we said yes
that's what I want yeah that's what I
Wolfgang Puck and red carpets and I want
to be around that I got to be around
that organic food you know if we really
cared about that and it was a huge
priority in our life then we could move
and go and pursue that but we just don't
so that's all all right thanks for that
for that email Derek and thanks
everybody for listening and watching
Godspeed